a blast rips through a cafe in Saint
Petersburg the windows shattering out
onto the street
16 people injured according to Russia's
interior Ministry and one man killed his
name was vladland tataski one of the
most prominent of Russia's pro-war
military bloggers honored in the Kremlin
after the annexations of four Ukrainian
regions he said then we will kill
everyone we will rob everyone we need
everything will be as we like tataski
was due to give a talk at the cafe which
local media says belongs to Wagner boss
yevgeni pregojin and hosts meetings at
the weekend under the name cyberfront
Zed
it's not clear who may have been behind
the attack
reports in local media say explosives
were hidden inside a statue presented to
tatasky as a gift
but if it was a targeted killing it
would be the second assassination of the
prominent nationalist figure on Russian
soil since the War Began
last August Daria dugina the daughter of
a well-known nationalist philosopher was
killed in a car bombing outside of
Moscow Russia blamed the Ukrainian
Security Services for her assassination
tataski like dugana was perhaps not
prominent enough to have much in the way
of security and although this killing
may see the ultra-nationalist Camp
respond with calls for revenge against
Ukraine any investigation still has a
long way to go dynamagne Sky News Moscow